car langue de l'uqam il a été la
révélation du dernier festival de cannes
loquace d'hondt 27 ans un réalisateur
qui prend son comédien par la main en
montant chercher sa caméra d'or car ce
premier film girl est indissociable de
son interprète victor polster
époustouflant dans le rôle de lara une
jeune danseuse en souffrance carnet dans
un corps de garçon à cannes girl a
scotché la croisette
les réactions 1 du public était vraiment
un c'était super c'était beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on avait imaginé que je pense
depuis le film enchaîné les festivals et
à chaque fois il bouleverse les
spectateurs qui était un véritable
prodige c'est un acte grave qui vient
faire la photographie d'un corps en
mouvement encore en transition celui
d'un adolescent qui veut à tout prix
être elle même une fille prenne pour une
fille ou pour un mec qui fuit
de télérama au figaro le film fait
l'unanimité de la presse toutes
sensibilités confondues
je sens que le film fait vraiment
quelque chose avec avec les gens qui le
voit pourquoi ce portrait d'une jeune
fille transgenres nous émeut autant
come on girl non seulement révèle un
cinéaste mais aussi inventé un
personnage qui a tout pour devenir culte
[Musique]
son visage d'ange cette échappée d'un
tableau de la renaissance vite capturé
par les photographes cannois victor
polster à 16 ans il est danseur et ça se
voit on l'a cueilli au lendemain la
toute première projection de girls bien
avant les lauriers bravo pour le grand
écart merci c'était super marrant vous
amuser de le faire c'est votre premier
protocole bah oui oui tout est une
première fois
ah oui exactement et comment est ce que
vous voyez tout ça c'est si gigantesque
ce qui a plein de trucs qui se passait à
chaque fois c'est un fou j'avais jamais
pensé que ça allait se passer en fait
c'est incroyable
magie de cannes qui du jour au lendemain
propulse un jeune homme encore à l'école
sur le devant de la scène dans girl il
fascine les spectateurs dans le rôle de
lara une jeune ballerine en mal de
féminin
vous avez dû vous transformer la plus
grande transformation c'était les
pointes
parce que c'est quelque chose que les
garçons ne font pas donc j'ai dit là
prendre trois mois ce qui est assez
court mais j'ai aussi été chez une femme
pour ma voix qui est un aspect assez
grand parce que ça ne veut pas être une
fois complètement féminine parce que
parce que lara dans le film est encore
en transition et aussi forcément les
extensions et le maquillage les séances
habillage et ça vous a plu cette
métamorphose de vous voir devenir femme
où je trouve ça assez marrant surtout le
regard des autres personnes qui savaient
pas en fait que je que je joue un rôle
parce que les gaz extension par exemple
je les gardais à la fin de la journée et
en fait il y avait que moi qui savais
que c'était un rôle et elle ne savait
pas donc j'ai trouvé cette rue main ses
airs de biche attire son visage
androgyne a tapé dans l'oeil de lukasz
dont réalisateur bienveillant qui
pendant un an et demi à chercher un
corps pour incarner lara ce garçon qui
se voit fille je savais pas si je
voulais avoir une fille ou un jeune
homme ou un jean phi une jeune fille tu
ranges ans et donc nous avons faire
encore sting son genre et nous avons vu
500 jeunes et dans une haie groupe il
était victor et je me rappelle très bien
qu'on victoire entraîne la salle de
danse que je l'avais immédiatement vu et
pour moi c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui
transcendait la genre c'était quelqu'un
qui était comme dit garçon n'y fit
[Musique]
et quand on est là quand il a commencé à
lancer je voyais son élégance et son
discipline
l'histoire de la rade en girl c'est un
violent conflit intérieur une quête
d'identité absolue certes accueilli avec
douceur par sa famille mais que pèse
l'amour des proches quand on ne
reconnaît pas son propre record en
faisant 1-1 vendredi par le château
frontenac et à chaque fois des personnes
que j'admire beaucoup qui m'impressionne
beaucoup en fait de déjà à cet âge-là
savoir ce qu'on veut devenir un pays en
être sûrs et et avoir tellement envie de
devoir changer que ce que ça devienne
vraiment une nécessité et vous en avez
rencontré oui pour le film avait
rencontré plusieurs comme la personne
dont ils m'inspirent et ses dents lisant
un article dans un journal belge que
luca ce don a eu l'idée de girls
une apprentie danseuse née garçon se
voyait refuser l'entrée dans une classe
de filles
le film par sa maturité à impressionner
le jury de la caméra d'or qui récompense
le meilleur premier film projeté à
cannes je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais attendu ce personnage pendant
des années qu'il n'était jamais vraiment
vont et que je le voyais pour la
première fois de ma vie et surtout de me
suis dit c'est faux je crois que cette
personne m'a manqué et j'étais très
heureuse de faire la connaissance de ce
personnage est ce que ce personnage là
est-ce qu'il arrive au bon moment sur
les questions de genre sur les questions
de voilà comment naviguer dans ces
questions et comment peut-être abattre
certains stéréotypes
il arrive avec une justesse sur tout
qui est assez étonnante et des gens qui
sont pas forcément sensible à la
question en sont ressortis tout aussi
émue oui les larmes coulent à chaque
avant-première chaque festival où le
film a été projeté depuis cannes loquace
donc qu'on surnomme déjà le xavier dolan
belge portes sont fines de ville en
ville rencontre le public ici au méliès
à montreuil il ya quelques jours vous
allez découvrir mon premier long métrage
qui s'appelle goran elle est devenue une
héroïne personnel de moi et j'espère que
après aujourd'hui elle va être votre os
en fait depuis cannes depuis cinq six
mois là vous êtes vous avez à un agenda
de rockstar un peu oui c'est un peu un
tournée assez chargé nous avons pas
vraiment arrêter nous sommes allés à
colorado à toronto à san sebastian en
pologne donc nous sommes allés un peu
partout et mais c'est cool
vous avez le sentiment que vous avez
créé un personnage qui jusque là
n'existait pas au cinéma qu'on n'avait
pas vraiment vu j'ai le sentiment que je
l'avais vu mais chaque fois que j'avais
vu un personnage comme ça je voyais
combattre le monde autour d'elle et je
pense que ce que j'avais pas vu c'est
vraiment voir ce personnage est
focalisée sur sept mondes intérieurs 7
conflits intérieurs avec avec sept corps
c'est quelque chose que j'avais pas déjà
vu moi-même baptême les faits moi je
sais pas
peut-être
c'est pas un problème si tu peux le dire
mais je dirais mais je sais pas on va
manger avec moi ce soir
on a fait un petit copain par exemple
mon père était à la première à cannes
avant ils avaient un peu peur du film
parce qu'ils pensaient que ce sujet sera
pas pour lui
est ce qui a été très bien c'est
qu'après le film il
il m'a dit très honnêtement qu'il était
vraiment touché et qu'il a pour la
première fois peut-être compris un peu
mieux comment savent eux doit être pour
vraiment être dans un corps qui
ressemble pas tant genre gageons que ce
personnage d'ado transgenres si rare au
cinéma va faire des petits promesse de
nouveaux récits d'histoires d'un nouveau
genre